I never got anything from that
relationship it's almost funny but what
was a good son in your eyes to to answer
her medical problems to show up and
visit regularly and to be available to
be there and not if I can you know pop
off any of this [__] when she
started firing at me and uh
it's funny uh she used to yell a lot and
we arranged a caretaker for her and I
felt Vindicated when this woman said to
me she she goes no you know it's great
we're gonna put the yelling the yelling
I got the yelling I thought imagine
you're three and that's going on yeah
how long did it take you to get that
Vindication how many years
some people die before they ever get it
you know what I mean
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
please